chose qui m'étonne beaucoup et qui
m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est votre manière de considérer les
femmes dans certaines de vos chansons et
surtout dans certaines de vos chansons
qui parlent la mort une chanson dans ce
disque qui s'appelle je crois le dernier
repas où les femmes ne semblent pas
admises il y en a une dont j'ai oublié
le nom où il était question aussi le
moribond c'est ça où il est question
aussi que les femmes soient exclus d'une
certaine manière ce sera rue oui c'est
un peu ça veut dire que le dernier repas
jeudi que comme en dernière page
voudraient les voir tout justement ce
que la manière la plus le plus horrible
de dire que que qu'il n'y en a pas eu
peut-être ça qui est étonnant parce que
il y a beaucoup de vedettes masculines
de stars disons des stars si vous disant
des stars masculines je sais pas si
c'est si ces deux mises à mal toute
façon star il faut de peu il ya beaucoup
de vedettes masculines qui est je crois
que c'est une certaine habitude du
métier qui vivent d'une certaine manière
en trombe il y a les femmes charmantes
plus compliquée qu avec le plusieurs de
vos joueurs exactement
et puis il y a les compagnons de travail
et c'est ça qui est plus important que
tout je crois que ça n'existe pas
uniquement à ces deux gars qui qu'ils
font et c'est un petit peu anormal comme
nous oui mais on est tout le temps là de
toute l'année on se promène toute
l'année et on se remet avec des hommes
c'est impensable c'est toute l'année
avec des femmes croyable dans la semaine
avec des hommes et il arrive peut-être
qu'on est une petite couleur des femmes
qui soient pas la plus jolie
parce que effectivement nous en
rencontrons tous même pas mal qui sont
vraiment pas intéressant du tout qu'ils
sentent attirés par ce par cette
ambiance de machin c'est parce qu'elles
croient justement sa dette et à paris à
tout ce bazar
alors eux seuls qu'on voit c'est pas
rigolo du tout ça n'est pas fait pour
rehausser le prestige de la femme dans
la civilisation
voilà alors peut-être qu'on a là on en
rit un petit peu trop et une tâche peut
être un peu trop d'importance à des
choses comme l'amitié où la chaleur des
hommes mais je pense pas ça peut
peut-être transparaître l'aï vraiment
mais de toute façon le fait de vivre
entre hommes et une chose de merveilleux
je trouve fantastique ah non ce n'est
pas plus facile du tout ah non non parce
que vivre en compagnie de certaines
femmes est l'acte le plus paresseux et
c'est un acte de vampires très souvent
on s'en remet doucement à l'amour d'une
dame
et puis quand même le on a fait le tour
de cet amour on s'en va et ouais si
c'est ça être normal et généreux je suis
d'abord je n'avais pas parlé j'avais
parlé oui mais je parle d'ailleurs en
mon nom je parle je crois ou non john
key gif surtout entre sam ans ce qui est
très étonnant
plus tôt ce qui me rassure et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tout à l'heure
vous m'avez parlé
comment dire je veux pas vous parler de
votre vie privée mais disons que vous
m'avez donné une définition sans le
vouloir une définition du couple qui est
quand j'ai dit que je peut il arriver
certains moments dans la vie je crois ou
un homme peut se dire ça y est je peux
être malade
enfin malades de n'importe quelle façon
quelqu'un me tiendront debout
maintenant c'est encore peut-être une
idée que je me fais plaisir
oui mais je pense que c'est peut-être de
mauvais je pense pas qu axa oui je pense
en tous les cas c'est qu'il décrivait
les finitions du coup pour qu'on puisse
donner je sais pas je sais pas c'est
quoi ça sert à ça mais ça sert souvent à
sap comme ça en tant qu'homme je ne suis
pas du tout pas qui veut je crois qu'en
35 existe aussi une espèce de solidité
une espèce de béton qui formidable que
les femmes comprennent maintenant argent
réalité un très souvent j'ai pas dis je
prends pas mes mains mes enfants en
général les femmes comprennent mal ce
genre de faisans de choses les hommes
partent souvent à deux les chais leur
plaît leurs clubs respectifs